wouldn't that be great if it was just
eddie murphy as like dressed as eddie
murphy but he's like i'm a dragon and
everyone's just like no you're not
you're a guy
he's like no my name's mushu i'm a luck
dragon come on mulan let's go
let's talk about the most annoying
disney sidekicks nina what's the most
annoying disney sidekick in your opinion
uh i had a tough time choosing here
because i find a lot of them really
annoying
to be honest with you and my first
instinct was the gargoyles from
hunchback of notre dame a solid pick
two of whom were named victor and hugo
which is the author of the novel
and the third one's just named laverne
which has like nothing to do with
anything
like they were like all right victor
hugo
uh laverne and one of them is voiced by
jason alexander and he's terrible he's
terrible in the part oh and it's also
like this is a really
like this is one of disney's darker
movies and it really undercuts
like the better parts of the movie to
have like jason alexander's gar girl
playing poker with a bunch of pigeons
and like throwing croissants at people
and it sucks but the real one i want to
take to task today is olaf from frozen
who i hate
and uh he's the worst part he's the
worst part of frozen
i haven't seen frozen two but i can only
assume that he's also the worst part of
frozen two um his whole thing is he's a
snowman who wants to walk into the
like warm embrace of death and play in
the sun which is weird yeah yeah he just
doesn't want to be around
he doesn't want to be around anymore and
he does it in the most annoying way
possible and
i just know i'm not alone in this
because there was a really long like
short before a pixar movie starring olaf
that disney had to remove from
theatrical releases
because every parent was like please
stop
so i remember that i just know that
everybody like with a a let it go
obsessed kid
shares my olaf disdain and like no
offense to josh gad i saw him in book of
mormon i love josh gad but like this
character sucks
i've had way too much of olaf and like
he's he's also like jarring to look at
he's supposed to be cute but he looks
like a horror show like
i every time i look at him i just think
of that horror movie where like a
truck
full of nuclear waste combines with the
truck with the serial killer in it and
turns into jack frost
um does anyone is anyone aware of that
movie
the vhs cover was a hologram so it
looked like a snowman and then when you
moved it it looked like a snowman with
jagged murder teeth um yeah a holiday
classic but yeah i like that's what olaf
brings to mind for me is like it i feel
like he's just ready to murder people he
he doesn't want to be like on this on
the planet um but yet he yet he persists
like if that's his greatest wish you
know go for it maybe no one's no one's
gonna
lose a lot of sleep
sorry ola
i'm sorry
no i'm with nina i think i think if he's
if he started to melt i would be like
all right
okay
this is so the movie would improve
i mean where did you think this was
gonna go tom yeah i i didn't assume that
it was gonna be let's kill olaf
i'll say that was not i didn't say kill
i said i said melt like just grab a hair
dryer and go to work you see he decides
that he wants to die let's just watch
him do it he'll go i didn't say watch i
just said listen you know
in the sun
out of any character olaf has the best
chance at coming back right he's part of
the water cycle yeah
he's in the ecosystem just let him
thank you that's a good point do you
hear that kids you could be drinking
olaf right now
every time you make a snowball it could
be olaf anytime you take a shower
or you go to the bathroom olaf's there
with you
this is for all the kids watching the
loop video
yeah
they're popular among the the eighth oh
god yeah so that's my answer
tom who's your who's your pick for the
most annoying disney sidekick you know i
didn't really have a specific one i i i
it's kind of like a five or six way tie
between kind of to what nina was talking
about any time that they took
a a a serious dark
terrifying story
and and
it seems like there was this
conversation that must have happened
about a half a dozen times at disney
where they were like we can either not
make this a children's movie
or
we could pile a funny sidekick onto it
and watch the kids so like
like the the zany raccoon from
pocahontas and the oh yeah the the
gargoyles i mean the the jason alexander
thing doesn't bother me that was
basically par for course like you find
somebody who's not working as much
anymore and they're a recognizable
comedic actor from back in the day like
he was on seinfeld at the time wasn't he
wasn't yeah
yeah and also in the aftermath of like
robin williams being kind of a huge
celebrity voice in aladdin that kind of
kick-started like famous people doing
voices in animated movies right again
credit
credit yeah against his wishes but yeah
credit where credit is due lindsay ellis
has an amazing video yes yes and that's
where i learned that you should
definitely check out her video about it
but yeah i think i mean with the
gargoyles in in
in hunchback does it help at all that
they're clearly figments of his twisted
imagination
i mean that make it a little bit more
palatable it definitely would have if
aren't they like an active part of the
third act though like aren't they
they're chucking rocks at people during
the revolution yeah i never i didn't
ever think they were part of his
imagination because there's other magic
in that movie so i was like i guess the
guard girls could move they're just real
gargoyles i just assumed i haven't seen
that movie for
probably 20 years i wouldn't if it was a
fight club thing where they were in his
brain that would be better um
yeah i would then i'd be like they're my
favorite sidekick i do think they're
supposed to be real
oh wow yeah which yeah exactly
no but i know what you're talking about
though they kind of do a toy story thing
where whenever anybody else shows up
they freeze right
right right
yeah wouldn't that would that have been
cool if it was somehow tied into the
other disney gargoyle property that they
were like cousins of the cool gargoyles
oh absolutely yeah i don't understand
why they didn't do that crossover
between them yeah
goliath shows up at the end of the of
the movie and is like you've all been
very mean to quasimodo
keith david
it's like
yeah i don't know and then he chews out
all like the tinier gargoyles for having
stupid names he's like choose a
choose neighborhoods in new york next
time that's right yes yeah
yeah laverne change your name to
something cool
yeah
like all right i'm upper east side now
[Laughter]
um
okay
so what did you have man yeah my pick is
controversial
ooh
my pick's really controversial we
already tried to kill a snowman today so
let's let's
bring it home my pick my pick for most
annoying disney sidekick
and i have reasons
is the genie from aladdin
bulls
here's why
here's why i picked such a spicy pick
number one first of all he's great he's
great in the movie okay he's very good
why thank you for that caveat yeah too
good perhaps right the movie's called
aladdin not
genie
that's number one overshadows our hero
right it's easy to overshadow aladdin
but that's what i'm saying this is a
movie about aladdin but all we can talk
about is genie this genie that right
that's number one
number two
all of his references are very topical
and dated references there's bob hope
references
there's kids in the 90s loved
nicholson
right like right he does he does the
shining a movie children count
definitely would have seen at the time
my kid is two right now right when i
showed him this movie in a couple of
years the genie is going to be doing all
his wacky zany stuff
and
my kid is going to be like what is he
talking about what is what is all of
this why are why i don't understand any
of these references papa i assume he'll
call me papa
and i'll have to explain to him
these are all references that pre-date
even my childhood and i was a child when
this movie came out and i don't know
that i can name all of these references
because this was for the my parents so
you're great or worse you'll have to be
like well the shining is a movie about
alcoholism and despair
and they're referencing the final act
where a father tries to kill his family
[Music]
yeah
do they do they do a shining reference
in aladdin i know they do jack nicholson
they do jack nicholson i don't know i
don't think he i don't think he's his
i thought he did something from the
shining um i mean they do it later in
finding nemo so it's still a problem in
other kids movies they do a shining
reference in finding nemo the shark is
chasing nemo and he goes here's bruce
and then he forces his way through like
a yeah oh my god there you go see that's
a jaws reference and a and a shining rod
yeah i don't think that's all
that's not how kids enjoy movies though
right brian i mean like you you like
like yeah i feel like kids are like
he's making funny noises and they're
flying and there's someone
yeah yeah i know
i just wanted to pick something
controversial just some you wanted
something spicy some hearts yeah yeah i
actually really like the genie in
aladdin i i don't stand by this cake at
all if anyone's watched this long
without hitting the thumbs down button
in terms of overshadowing the hero do
you think that mushu overshadows mulan
mushu is actually far more annoying i
was gonna say mushroom's way more
annoying mushy is much worse yes yeah i
agree
which falls into that same category i
was talking about before it's like this
is the story of a young woman right
a lot of people and who like is doing it
so her dad doesn't die in battle
right
a couple years later as donkey and you
were like dude doing the exact same
thing yeah yeah
and i mean there's a reason that they
didn't add mushu to the live-action
you know mulan remake you know there's
no room there's no room for him they
they didn't have they should i'm
imagining that with horror
i was 100 i was i was holding my breath
the entire time i was waiting for
updates on that live action move on i
was like who are they gonna bring you
and eddie murphy returning as mushu oh
god wouldn't that be great if it was
just eddie murphy as like dressed as
eddie murphy but he's like i'm a dragon
and everyone's just like no you're not
you're a guy
he's like no my name is mushu i'm a luck
dragon come on
after
afternoon we got 20 hours
after his prestige films have like not
gotten the oscars he wants i would not
put anything past this man at this point
that'd be great though like he's like
dolomite is my name didn't get the
attention it deserved i'm just gonna
wear a like an anti-circus suit and
pretend i'm a lizard
i don't even want him to wear an andy
circus suit i want him to just think
there's no green applied he's just in
the suit with the little bubbles on it
like they don't
they don't do any effects he's just
wearing that like tracy jordan and and
normal from 30 rock exactly
him just exactly
like dark knight style he's like he he
hires a pilot to like
fly him in under the radar into china to
shoot this movie yeah without having
been invited
he keeps air dropping onto the set like
they're like
like eddie murphy is returned
yeah
so i'm officially changing my answer
from genie to mushu because genie was
mostly just so that i could say
something controversial but i can't i
don't stand by it mushu
it's mushu yeah sorry sorry everyone i
didn't mean to mislead you but i kinda
did
thanks for watching please hit like and
subscribe
[Music]